and well at Roscoe is an expert on the
region and doesn't believe Ukraine's key
agricultural sector is profitable at all
right now why not mr. óscar we're
talking about a country rich in minerals
and resources and one with some of the
best quality soil in the world he
explained that first of all to me it was
a factoid that I stumbled across that I
found very interesting I'm sure a lot of
people don't know yeah I'm quite sure
that many people know at least from my
generation because you're Korean somehow
has been misused as we all know at least
in Germany for supplies as raw materials
supplies for food under industry for
Germany so yeah we do know we remember
from historian times so a lot of coal
and and oil deposits are these things
that are missing but at the same time
its soil is so good why is that this so
plays a very important role why it's so
good necessaries not this I cannot
explain but but it has one of the
world's the third world largest
percentages of fertile black soil and
yet despite having all of that fertile
black soil we're talking about an
agricultural sector that's not so
profitable in your opinion if compared
to European Union averages if you talk
about grain yields or something like
that it's almost about half of
profitability well why is that there are
many reasons for that
some of them are simply poor technology
and as we see this is a case for me to
Germany some of them are stemming from
former communist times that this poor
organisation poor management
why are those structures still so
entrenched in a country in which so many
people wanted to move away from that
past
there's lots of info infrastructure that
is needed for agriculture this is not
only sewing or collecting you need
transport infrastructure you need roads
you need ports you need vessels so
there's a lot of infrastructure that you
need that costs a lot of money
is that by the EU could help out for
sure and I'm quite sure that you will
help because otherwise the plans don't
work out could we see a four-fold
increase in output in the agricultural
sector some experts are predicting I
would be interested in knowing where
these experts are from I guess from
Monsanto maybe if you if you go the way
and heavy agreeing cos I agree
industrial agriculture ring then maybe
there would be a potential for such an
increase but that would be very
extensive and very focused on raw
materials production but if you go a
more intensive way then I think a
two-fold increase might be realistic
okay so invest it should stay realistic
just lastly a final word for me what way
would you like to see the Ukrainian
economy move I would like you Crimean
economy not to move back and to
historian former times as a as a
producer only of raw materials I would
like to see Ukraine move forward to
producing when you add it along the
value chain that means also food
processing and for production mister I
thank you very much for coming in today
pleasure